SHOOTING DEATH OF DATE WRIGHT.
HERE TO REACT IS DAVID WEBB,
HOST OF REALITY ECK ON FOX
NATION.
THANKS F BEING WITH US TODAY
ANMERRY CHRISTMAS TO.
THIS IS A TRAGIC STORYBOTH 5, DO
ACKNOWLEED IT WAS A MISTAKE,
SHE GRABBED TASER BUT THE
CONCLUSION WAS IT WAS
GLIGENCE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
VERDICT?
>> YOU SAID IT.
A TRAGIC SUATION.
M POTTER'S LIFE IS NOW RUINED
MANY WILHAVE SPENT TIME
LITIGATI OR RELITIGATINGHE
SE AND TALKING ABOUTT, THE
SYSTEM HAS SPOKE SHE HAS THE
RIGHT TO APPEAL.
I WOULD THER FOCUS ON E
MESSAGTORIMINALS AND
WOULBE CRIMINALS AND AMECANS
WRIT LARGE.
WHEN YOU DON'T COMY WITH THE
POLICE, TAKEOUR CELL DOWN A PAT
TYPE OF SIATIO DAUNTE WRIGHT
WAS RTAINLY NOT INNOCENTI AM
NOT SAYING HE DESERV TO DIE.
WAS A TRAGIC MISTAKE BY THE
POLICEFFICER.
BUT HAD HE NOT GONE DOWN TT
PATH WRE HE WAS FACING
WITHELONY CHARGES, HE'S T A
SINNER THAT SHOULDTURNED
TO A SAINT.
THLESSON HERE IS FOR US TO
EXAMINE THE SITUATION AND TAKE
IT FORWARD ANDAY HOW DO WE
KEEP CHILDREN, YOUNG PEOPLE AWAY
FROM THIS TYPEF SITUATION.THERE
WRIGHTS AND FU KIM POTTERS.
BENJAMIN: VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS, WILL BE BEER IF SHE
WAS A WHITE MA
I WANT TO REVI THIS IN THE NEW
RK TIMES.
MISS HARRIS TOLD HER ALLIES, 48
MALE.
WITH THE INTRACTABLE ISSUES
HER POFOLIO LIKE VOTING RIGHTSI
IMMIGRATION AND THE APPROVA
RATING, 50% DISAPPROVE.
WHAT DO YOSAY?
>> HE IS A PROGRESSI, SELF
ENTIFY AS A WHITE MAN AND GET
TTER COVERAGE, COME ,
REALLY?
KAMALA HARRIS HAS FAID TO DO
R JOB.
SHE HASN'T OPENED E PORTFOLIO
OR LOOKED AT IT OR DELIBETELY
CHOSEN, THERE'S A ISIS ON THE
BORDER.
TO GO TO THE CTER, DUG INTO
THE ROOT CAUSES.
THISS NOT PART OF THE LEFS
AGENDATHE PROGRESSIVE LE OF
WHICH SHE IS THEIREADER, VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNID STATES,
PUSHING FOR THEIR N OPEN
RDER PROCESSES TAKING THEM
DOWN, TO STO AND GOOD FOR THE
STATE OF TEXAS FOR SPPING UP
WHERE THE FEDEL GOVERNMENT
FAILS TOO ITS JOB, THE STATE
MUST.BENJAMIN: YOU NTIONED THEY
HANDLING T BORDER.
USE DEMOCRATS SLAMMED HARRIS
ON THE BORDER, S FAILED TO
RETURN H COLD, HENRY
RACHEL: CUELLAR REACHED T AND
SA THIS.
SHE WAS TASK WITH THE JOB, DOES
TERESTED IN THIS.
WEOVE ON TO OTHER FOLKWHO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE GING UP ON
HELP FROM HER AND LOOKING
ELSEWHERE.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU?
>> HE RECOGNIZES WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEON A DAILY
BASIS, WHAT EY SEE AA TRAIN
ECK OF AUATION, AN
ENVIRONMENTAL NIGHTMARE, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING KER, DRUGS
CROSSING THE BORDER, SAUDI
ARIAN MAN OF INTEREST EA
MANY TERRORIST GROUPJUST
ARSTED AT THE BORDER.
WHAT ABOUT THE ONES WEON'T
KN, THE ONES THAT GOT AWAY
HE SEES THIS REITY AND THE
REALITY IS KALA HARRIS HAS NO
INTEREST FROM ATTORN GENER
TO VICPRESIDENT, CAN BARELY
GAER ENOUGH ATTENTION.
SHE WAS TO GET PREDENT BIDEN
ELECTED AND W SHE HAS FAILED
IS EXPECTED BUT THE ILURE
REALLY COMES DOWN  THE
AMICAN PEOPLE PAYING THE PRICE
NOT JUST ON THE BOER BUT
ACROSS A COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
ADNISTRATION, INVITING
ILLEGALS TO COME IN AND ING
RECES, TAXPAYERS OF AMERICA
PAID FOR TO TAKE CAROF ILLEGAL
ALIENS.